Newark New Jersey has seen its share of
hard times most recently like Flint
Michigan it's found itself battling a
lead water crisis but a lot is looking
up in the Brick City crime has hit in
historic 50 year low and the jobless
rate has dropped to to about a third of
what it was just four years ago some of
that success is thanks to innovative
public-private partnerships like the one
forum between the city and the audiobook
company audible these improvements are
not only transforming the city but also
the lives of its residents how did you
find this place this is just one of the
great buildings in Newark that we've
just embraced you might think the
world's largest producer and seller of
audiobooks would be in Seattle or
Silicon Valley it's the right thing to
do and a lot of reasons why but audible
founder Don Katz just expanded his
company into the soul of downtown Newark
are these new no they were written were
original they were from 1932 so the
church burned down audibles new home is
this once abandoned 100 year old church
that's gone from house of worship to
work space this was the original choir
loft where people gather to brainstorm
and create ideas it's called the
innovation Cathedral so what are people
doing here so they're building various
technologically oriented products these
are mostly software development
engineers in fact audible has become
Newark's fastest-growing private
employer with a workforce of more than
1,600 in the city all engineering a new
frontier of entertainment audible didn't
just leave reading alone and if you
think about it there are millions and
millions and millions of people is
inaudible not because we looked at the
concept of reading and then thought
about refracting it through this artful
performances by actors flannel blanky
toes but it's not just hat being
developed here
it's young minds to
as a partner in the city's education
system audible donated more than four
million dollars over the past year by
giving Newark public high school
students in Amazon tablet headphones and
an audible subscription I was a book
nerd book nerd oh definitely I read a
lot of books it also offered students
like Nicole ransom internships and a
paycheck
oh yeah you paid I started out with $14
an hour mm-hmm so that that's a lot a
pretty good investment of my time CEO
Don Katz got his start as a journalist
but developed into a true tech innovator
he's credited with creating the first
digital audio player back in 1997 four
years before Apple came out with the
iPod I was supposed to do a book about
you know the digital media revolution
like 25 years ago and instead of writing
the book I saw that people would be
running around with little digital
devices filled with civilization they'd
be in your pocket one thing which came
after another and I decided to create a
company instead of write about it
audible grew so fast that by 2008 Amazon
paid a reported 300 million dollars to
buy it how much did Amazon change the
equation the beautiful thing is that we
have a currently really independent
culture brand and business model they're
very much support what we're doing a
newer do they you know necessarily agree
with everything we're doing I don't
really know all I know is that we've had
an amazing run here the company moved
from neighboring Elizabeth New Jersey to
Newark in 2007 just as new blood swept
into City Hall clear to me that they've
been a good part of it part of they have
great intentions and doing what they can
do
Mayor Ross Parata is the latest reformer
pushing big ideas including a goal of
having Newark based corporations like
audible Prudential and Panasonic to hire
2,000 local residents by next year we
need to make sure they train and work
with new residents meet them make sure
they help us in the schools that get
kids prepared the promise of better days
is helping to erode the stigma
associated with Newark's past
the 1969 uprising exposed police
brutality and job inequality and also
drove thousands of residents out
draining the city of its once mighty tax
base and political accountability those
days are gone but as some degree of
prosperity returns Baraka hopes to
ensure his city's comeback won't leave
those who've always lived here behind
the economy grows in the city is our job
as leaders and elected here in the town
to make sure that wealth that comes in
the community is redistributed in such a
way that the majority of residents can
see some benefit from it would you ever
have thought this was your future newark
new jersey no nope I thought that I was
going to move to California and do
something to cool out there a Jana post
is one example she found a job at
audible one year ago after struggling
through a tough adolescence I was living
in a homeless shelter here in Newark
called coven house yes and they have a
program here at audible called hire
local she will enroll in college next
year thanks to another audible program
that pays for the majority of tuition
for all employees it's changed her
trajectory all because the people who
create cutting-edge audio have also
learned to listen to the needs of those
around them they helped me shape my
future now by investing their training
their hiring for their programs
everything they've done has helped me
achieve what I am today we basically
said as long as you're bright and
gregarious we'll take it from there
have you been able to filter up that
talent pool in the high ranks of the
company our representative I'm more
interested in the organic impact you're
creating jobs at all levels for all
kinds of people this Cathedral is filled
with people have come from all over the
world they're at the top of their game
in technology and as Audibel continues
to change the way we enjoy books it's
helped open up a brand new chapter for
the City of Newark look everyone in
America loves a comeback story it's one
of a great kind of you know storytelling
kind of tropes and being part of it
actually has a lot of
a lot of meaning and uplifting character
and and you know I I would say the fact
that so many people want to work here is
justification enough to continue to try
to help the city yeah but here's some
other perks audible also gives their
employees free daily lunch an additional
five hundred dollars a month on top of
their salary to pay rent if they choose
to live in Newark and they even have a
bowling alley basement that's what a
great use of their resources and their
personnel and developing and growing I
love all of this yeah it's almost full
circle for Don cats because as a
journalist he was covering you know so
much of the unrest of the 60s he even
had introduced with the Black Panthers
so I mean he's really viewed as the kind
of guy who sees it and has seen it for a
very long time a couple things one is
just looking at that church is amazing
just the base it inside the church just
beautiful and then what he says about as
long as you're bright and we like that